it's a new year and with our economy
growing and a strong majority government
in power Britain begins it with renewed
strength there are no New Year's
resolutions for us just an ongoing
resolve to deliver what we promised in
our manifesto security at every stage of
your life over 31 million people will
begin the year in work more than any in
our history six million children will
start the new term and a good or
outstanding school more than half a
million workers will be taken out of
income tax in April as everyone apart
from the very best paid gets a tax cut
and for the lowest paid there will be a
new national living wage meanwhile
millions more will benefit from the free
childcare new academies rising pensions
and extra apprenticeships that we
committed to in our manifesto or as a
result of our long-term economic plan we
also promised something else in our
manifesto giving you a say on Europe and
now we're delivering on that promise
there will be an in/out referendum by
the end of 2017 it is written into the
law of the land I'm negotiating hard to
fix things that most annoy British
people about our relationship with the
EU there's just one thing that drives me
what is best for the national interest
of our country but in the end it will be
for you to decide is our economic and
national security and a dangerous world
better protected by being in or out we
also go into the year confronting some
deep social problems ones that have
blighted our country for too long
I want 2016 to be the time when we
really start to conquer them a crucial
year in this great turnaround decade
because with economic renewal and social
reform we can make everyone's lives more
secure so if you're one of the many
hard-working young people locked out of
the housing market we will deliver the
homes that
helped lead you to your own front door
if you're off school or out of work
trapped in an underworld of addiction
abuse crime and chaos we will sweep away
state failure and help give you
stability if your dreams have been
dashed simply because of who you are we
will fight discrimination and deliver
real opportunity to help lay your path
to success and we will take on another
social problem - when our national
security is threatened by a seething
hatred of the West one that turns people
against their country and can even turn
them into murderous extremists I want us
to be very clear you will not defeat us
and we will not just confront the
violence and the terror we will take on
their underlying poisonous narrative of
grievance and resentment we will come
down hard on those who create the
conditions for that narrative to
flourish and we will have greater
confidence in indeed we will revel in
our way of life because if you walk our
streets learn in our schools benefit
from our society you sign up to our
values freedom tolerance responsibility
loyalty these are the big challenges of
our age some of the biggest our nation
has ever faced and this year is a test
of our mettle whether we put up with
poverty or put an end to it ignore the
glass ceiling or smash it abandon the
tenant or help make them a homeowner
appease the extremists or take apart
their ideology piece by piece will get
Britain a better deal in Europe give
families the peace of mind they crave
and will make our country even more
secure that's what this year this
turnaround decade is all about so let me
wish everyone the very best and a very
happy new year